im netz häufen sich die
weltuntergangsszenarien zum 23 september
2017 die prophezeiung reichen von einem
planeten einschlag auf der erde bis hin
zur ausführlichen sie sich uns an
diesem tag offenbaren werden all diese
theorie stützen sich auf eine besondere
sternenkonstellation an diesem tag was
dran ist und was auf jeden fall an brian
fallon 2017 passieren wird denn es wird
etwas passieren
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum zwischen
herzlich willkommen
ehrlich gesagt ich kann es gar nicht
mehr zählen wie oft der erde
der weltuntergang bisher gedroht hat
eigentlich gibt es kaum ein jahr in dem
es nicht ein bestimmtes datum von
gewissen leuten mit spannung erwartet
wird bei verschiedenen
katastrophenszenarien vorausgesagt
werden im jahr 2000 weg sehen ist dies
der 23 september also bleibt uns mal
wieder nicht mehr wirklich viel zeit
unser leben so wie wir es bisher kennen
zu genießen eine besondere
sternenkonstellation an diesem tag soll
die basis für die verschiedenen vor
heerwagen liefern den vorschlag für
dieses videos den hat übrigens philipp
geliefert an dieser stelle herzlichen
dank also wie sie die sterne
konfiguration an diesem tag aus und was
ist das besondere und verzeiht mir die
blumige ausschmückung aber das sieht
einfach ungemein die verschiedenen
weltuntergangsszenarien wie ich euch
gleich vorstellen werde
von einem sternbild abzuleiten die sonne
soll astronomisch gesehen im haupt des
sternbildes jungen frau stehen der mond
zeitgleich zu ihren füßen das
sternbild löwe besteht aus neun sternen
und sondern diesem tag zudem noch durch
die drei planeten merkur venus und mars
ergänzt werden insgesamt also zwölf
himmelskörper die sich ausgerechnet am
23 september zum 17
am kopf der jungfrau ihrer krone quasi
befinden sollen einige gehen davon aus
dass zu dem jupiter auf einer linie
quasi zwischen den beinen der jungfrau
entlang wandern soll und damit jetzt
direkt zur ersten vorhersage die das
ganze spektakel als eine art planeten
geburtstag
das muss man den
verschwörungstheoretikern lassen sie
geben einfach nicht klein bei und
erwarten ja zum wirklich xten mal dass
ein unbekannter planet nahm niveau oder
planet xviii denen oft auch nennen die
erde zerstören wie man natürlich ganz
sicher am 23 september 2017 diese
theorie beschreibt beispielsweise der
britische autor und
verschwörungstheoretiker david mit
ausführlichen büro soll demnach am
südpol einschlagen und wohl den
großteil aller menschen vernichten
einige der verschwörungstheorie wir
gehen davon aus dass die öffentlichkeit
über dieses ereignis bewusst im
unklaren gelassen wird damit sich nur
die elite darauf vorbereiten kann das
thema hatten wir schon mal
denn ähnliche vorhersagen weder für
2009 noch für 2012 noch für 2015 oder
2016 eingetreten inhaltlich stützen
sich die anhänger dieser theorie ihrer
überzeugung nach auf die nasa die den
mit der löwen planeten die beruf vor
längerer zeit einmal mit dem ihrer
satelliten beobachtet haben soll wer des
untergangs fanatiker sind nämlich davon
überzeugt dass die nasa niveau 1983
entdeckt hat aber seit dem tod schweiz
um eine massenpanik auf der erde zu
vermeiden jeder wissenschaftliche
beitrag indem irgendwie der begriff
planet iks vorkommt wird von ihnen als
bestätigung für ihre katastrophen
szenarien angesehen was war wirklich
dahintersteckt den begriff plane takes
den gibt's ja im wissenschaftsrat welche
hier steht aber für einen
hypothetischen planeten in der äußeren
regionen des sonnensystems und na klar
auch die nasa sucht nach unbekannten
planeten im äußeren sonnensystem doch
mit dem welt verschwörerischen büro
dessen existenz nicht mal bewiesen ist
hat das nur macht überhaupt nichts zu
tun die nasa hatte ja tatsächlich zu
dem planeten geäußert und entwarnung
gegeben ihr könnt euch also entspannen
aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach hätten
astronomen solche einen hobby astronomen
durch einen planeten der auf dem weg in
richtung erde wäre schon seit einiger
zeit auf dem schirm er müsste
inzwischen jedem von jedem entdeckt
worden seien und er wäre mittlerweile
sogar mit dem bloßen auge erkennbar
also abhaken büro werden wir nicht zu
gesicht bekommen geschweige denn wird er
die welt zerstören aber auch einige
passionierte liebe leser erwarten den 23
september 2017 mit spannung die
konstellation der sterne an diesem tag
soll nämlich einen bestimmten verkauf
der liebe nämlich 51 aus der
offenbarung johannes beschreiben und ein
großes teilchen wurde am himmel gesehen
eine frau umhüllt mit der sonne und der
mond war unter ihren füßen und eine
krone von zwölf sterne war auf ihrem
auf und sie war schwanger und sie
schreibt in ihrem wehen und
geburtsschmerzen für einige jetzt muss
schon sagen fanatische bibel anhänger
dieser bibeltext exakte beschreibung des
sternbildes an diesem tag die sonne
steht im haupt des sternbildes jungfrau
der mond zeitgleich zu ihren füßen das
sternbild lösen
den sternen unserer sieben tag zudem
noch von drei planeten merkur venus mars
inhalten insgesamt also zwölf
himmelskörper die ausgerechnet am 23
september 2017 wie sich am kopf der
jungen frau ihrer krone quasi befinden
sollen
das hatten wir ja schon mal und das
übrigens alles über der stadt
jerusalem das verleitet aber fanatische
bibel anhänger direkt zu mehreren
möglichen szenarien für den tag ihr
nur ein paar von ihnen heraus gepickt
der große kampf zwischen satan jesus
wird stattfinden
der kampf zwischen gut und böse die
dieser kommt von jesus ist nahe
die zeit des trips satz beginnt es
werden bemerkenswerte veränderung
stattfinden und und und wenn er mich
fragt ist das wie so oft in der religion
alles natürlich frei interpretierbar
und glaube da wird natürlich auch nicht
auf fakten
dennoch stimmen die details des
vorhergesagten sternbild nicht wirklich
mit dem bibeltext überein den planeten
sind nun mal keine sterne
aber das wusste man was man sicher noch
nicht und außerdem ist in vers 12 1 von
einer frau oder noch besser weit die
rede und nicht von an der jungfrau also
abgehakt und damit also weiter zur
nächsten theorie die außerirdischen
die habt ja bitte sagen sicher schon
vermisst so sind einige ufo
verschwörungstheoretiker überzeugt
davon dass uns am tanzen september 2010
endlich außerirdische über ihre
existenz informieren ob dies mehr oder
weniger liebevoll tun darüber sind sich
die ufo verschwörungstheoretiker setzt
aber noch nicht einig und falls euch
jetzt das vorausgesagte sternbild vom
anfang september 2017 irgendwie
auffüllt gebe ich euch noch die
folgenden fact mit auf den weg venus
jupiter natur sonne mond und mars
befinden sich an diesem tag
wahrscheinlich genau auf einer linie von
der erde aus gesehen
die formulierung auf einer linie lässt
allerdings immer etwas in der
fraktionsführung offen und natürlich
stehen alle wandel sterne immer etwa
ringsherum einer gedachten linie es gibt
zeiten da gleich die konzentration er
einer linie als eben zu anderen
zeitpunkten mit der tatsächlichen
konstellation im raum hat das rein gar
nichts zu tun und man wird es auch
leider nicht sehen können da die sonne
viel zu hell ist können wir also auch
abhaken hat mich und ver durch aber zum
schluss kann ich euch noch verraten
das kann sicher an diesem mysteriösen
tag passieren verpasst durch diesen
ganzen dieses ganze turbo nicht den
astronomischen herbstanfang am anfang
september die sonne wird an diesem tag
zwölf stunden über dem horizont stehen
und den äquator in südlicher richtung
überqueren so dass von nun an die tage
wieder kürzer als die nächte werden
wenn ihr keine videos mehr zu den
nächsten anstehenden weltuntergänge
kaputten wollten wir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergällt nicht den genau auf
die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
wird ein planet unsere erde zerstören
da geht es noch mal sehr detailliert um
libero wenn euch dieses weltuntergangs
szenario noch mehr interessiert dann um
den kauf klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran